اليك هشام ان تتواجد هناك
وضعنا في الصوره
والاجواء العامه طبعا نحن نشاهد هذه الصور
هناك مشاركه كبيره
للفلسطينيين هناك في غزه
للصلاه على
شهداء اليوم
[تصفيق]
هشام هل تسمعني
نعم مشاركه جماهيريه هناك اصوات هتافات
مرتفعه من هؤلاء الشبان الذين يهتفون
لهؤلاء الشهداء ويحيوهم
ويهتفون للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ويطالبونها
بالرد ويهللون ويكبرون
مع من
مع امن مع قرود جتامين هؤلاء الشهداء من
المسجد بعد اداء صلاه الجنازه هؤلاء
الشهداء هم وزوجاتهم وابنائهم
وبالتاكيد
سيحملون على الاكتاف
وسيتوجهون الى مثواهم الاخير الى المقبره
الشرقيه شمال قطاع غزه كما ترين هناك
اعلام لكل وجل الفصائل الفلسطينيه لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي ولا حركه حماس والاحرار
المجاهدين وجل الفصل حتى نركض الفتح
والجبه الشعبيه والديمقراطيه كلهم يرفعون
هذه الرايات ويحيون هؤلاء الشهداء الذين
يرون فيهم القدوه وانهم كانوا شهداء ضحوا
بانفسهم
وبارواحهم من اجل القضيه الفلسطينيه
والدفاع عن القضيه الفلس
طينيه وها هي جثامين الشهداء الان بدات
تسير في هذه المسيره
الشهداء هم من جيران قاده سرايا القدس
وبعضهم من ابنائهم وايضا من
زوجاتهم
القاده الثلاثه من سرايا القدس خلي
ل وجهاد الغنام جهاد الغنام سيشيع في رفح
وبدا موس وبدا تشيعه في رفح جنوب قطاع غزه
وطارق عز الدين وخليل البهتيني يشيعون
الان في غزه من هذا المسجد المسجد العمري
الكبير اسرائيل تتهم خليل البهتيني بانه
احد القاده البارزين في سرايا القدس وانه
المسؤول عن اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
وكذلك بانه مسؤول عن تنفيذ عمليات او
المحاوله تنفيذ عمليات في قلب اسرائيل قبل
ايام كان هناك رد من الغرفه المشتركه
وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه ردا على
اغتيال او كما اسمه اغتيال للشهيد والاسير
الفلسطيني خبر عدنان واسرائيل تتهم خليل
البهتيني بانه هو من اطلق هذه الصواريخ
باتجاه اسرائيل ردا على استشهاد الاسير
الفلسطيني خبر عدنان اليوم خليل البهتيني
يحمل على الاكتاف كما حمل خضر عدنان ومن
قبل تيسير الجعبري وابو العطا وجل الشهداء
الفلسطينيين الذين
اختلف
لا اله الا الله